Hola Muy bienvenidos una nueva emisión
de la entrevista de France 24 en español
nos acompaña en esta oportunidad felina
Santiago Valdivia eso ya pertenece al
pueblo zapoteco del estado de Oaxaca al
sur de México allí viven las mujeres
estamos hablando de un sector de la
sociedad al cual se lo conoce como el
tercer género y que hace a estallar al
binarismo reinante en casi todas las
sociedades frena Muchísimas gracias por
su presencia en France 24 en español
un gusto gracias por la invitación y
reciban un abrazo del sur de México
Muchas gracias gracias una vez más
felina para empezar no un tema clave que
es una muche
muchas es una identidad cultural propia
de la cultura zapoteca del istmo de
Tehuantepec
y que las caracteriza
bueno la forma de vida aquí en el disco
de Tehuantepec específicamente en
Juchitán y hay otros pueblos aledaños
como Tehuantepec Unión Hidalgo Santa
María shadani que tenemos una vida este
similar Pero hay pueblos
a 15 minutos de aquí donde la vida mucho
ya es diferente no que no tiene nada que
ver con con nuestra cultura nosotras
somos parte de la cultura aquí se
respeta el espacio del hombre de la
mujer de las lesbianas y por supuesto
que también las muchas tenemos un
espacio que con esfuerzo hemos ganado no
y cuéntenos no algo clave para que las
conozcas sobre todo nuestra audiencia
internacional no como es la vida de una
Muse no como nace y que va sucediendo a
lo largo de su vida
Bueno aquí este el descubrimiento es
colectivo no es individual desde que una
mucha empieza a caminar a hablar pues
antes de que la misma mucha sepa que es
mucha ya todos los demás saben que es
mucho las primas los tíos Los Hermanos
ya saben de que es mucho entonces este
conforme va los va pasando los años pues
las muchas vamos descubriendo de que
existen otras identidades no que existen
los hombres que existen las mujeres pero
nosotros no nos sentimos identificada
con ninguna de las dos nosotros tenemos
un espacio propio no estamos en medio de
los dos en medio del hombre y de la
mujer aquí la que es mucha Es mucha que
es hombres hombre es mujeres mujer
hablamos Bueno usted bien lo decía no
hombres mujeres muches hablamos de tres
identidades reconocidas para todo su
pueblo desde la época prehispánica
verdad y el origen de las mujeres
proviene de una creencia muy interesante
vinculada A la religión podría
contarnosla
bueno las hermosas siempre hemos
existido en toda la historia
independientemente que conforme ha
pasado el tiempo nuestras
características características
este físicas han cambiado este hemos
adoptado por ejemplo el maquillaje que
hace 50 años Pues aquí no había no había
el internet no había televisión entonces
hemos adaptado otras cosas para nuestra
vida personal pero ser mucha y No
necesariamente tienes que tener aspecto
femenino sino que también hay muchas un
aspecto varonil pero que son aceptados
en la sociedad como lo que son muchos
Hablamos de una aceptación no felina
cuéntenos Cómo es la convivencia entre
las luces y las personas que no son
buses
Bueno hay una convivencia de respeto
pero también
este hay discriminación no yo creo que
siempre hemos dicho de que la
discriminación va de la mano con la
ignorancia y mientras haya ignorancia en
cualquier Rincón del mundo va a haber
discriminación pero a diferencia de
otras partes Juchitán es un lugar donde
podemos caminar libremente por las
calles y hay un ambiente de respeto
entre los hombres las mujeres las
lesbianas cada quien en su espacio
nosotros no estamos invadiendo ni un
espacio nosotros luchamos día a día
también para salir adelante y tenemos
este este acceso no a lugares donde son
propiamente para hombres o para mujeres
pero que nosotras también podemos entrar
Nosotras también podemos participar en
la política nosotros participamos en los
eventos religiosos
Cómo hacer mayordomo de un evento
religioso es muy común aquí en Juchitán
y podemos tener este estudiar una
carrera hoy en día quería consultarle
ahora por algo que le había preguntado
previamente Pero bueno no pudimos
desarrollarlo porque bueno Se abrieron
otros temas bien interesantes no pero me
refería a ese origen aquella creencia
religiosa no usted la podrá desarrollar
creo que era si mal no recuerdo San
Vicente repartiendo unas semillas no y
tres costales
[Música]
que se cuenta alrededor de Las Musas Que
cuentan de que San Vicente Ferrer es el
santo patrón del pueblo entonces decían
de que San Pedro iba repartiendo las
semillas este en todos en todas partes
del mundo dejaba semillas masculinas
femeninas y semillas muses no entonces
cuentan de que este todas partes andabas
San Pedro este repartiendo las semillas
pero que llegando a Juchitán se le
rompió el costal de semilla mucho por
eso es que hay más muchas pero no es que
existan más mucha en Juchitán sino que
hay más visibilidad no somos más
visibles por esta oportunidad que
tenemos de caminar libremente de
vestirnos como queremos de trabajar o
sea algo que la gente lo ve normal No
hombre mujer
somos una persona más una sociedad
no quería consultarle bueno porque usted
también es una líder una referente no
está al frente del grupo de buses las
auténticas intrépidas buscadoras del
peligro cuéntenos primero Quiénes son y
por qué ese nombre tan particular
Pues yo soy de la segunda generación de
las intrépidas buscadoras del peligro
nace hace 47 años por lo mismo de de la
visibilidad para decir aquí estamos que
también tenemos derechos de festejarnos
de festejar la vida y de trabajar con
nuestra comunidad entonces nace hace 47
años en un pueblo cercano a Juchitán con
personas de Juchitán Posteriormente se
va haciendo esta vela se llaman velas
porque son veladas de noche que puede
ser este por ejemplo la vela de los
cueteros son las personas que hacen
cohete de Los Pescadores los que pescan
y así infinidad de velas que son fiestas
que a veces son una semana de fiesta no
lo que se lleva a cabo aquí en Juchitán
entonces pues las muchas También tenemos
nuestra fiesta y este yo soy como que
digo el de la segunda generación porque
compañeras Pues poco a poco se han ido
adelantando no entonces este hoy en día
pues en noviembre hacemos la fiesta de
étnica de la diversidad más grande no de
América Latina yo creo
quería por lo siguiente no por lo que he
estado leyendo escuchando También muchas
cosas que usted ha estado comentando hay
una idea de que las mujeres nacen así
quiero decir no consiguen su identidad
como una suerte de construcción social
cultural más bien hay una creencia de
que como decía no de que nacen de esa
manera
pues nacemos no la naturaleza no se
puede doblegar no se puede jugar porque
también para muchas que no viven en
Juchitán viven en otras partes para ella
hacer mucho Tampoco es fácil o ser
transgénero transexual tampoco una vida
así es fácil que como para que uno se
esté inventando eso no nosotros nacimos
desde desde niños como te decía antes de
salir nosotros que somos muchos y nos
vamos dando cuenta poco a poco no de Don
de nuestro lugar en esta sociedad de que
no solamente hay blanco y negro sino que
existen otras identidades y merecen ser
reconocidas no
como decía se rompe el sistema binario
para dar pasos a otras expresiones
como representante Muse no y bueno de
este pueblo tan particular no porque hay
muchísimas sociedades en las que todavía
es muy difícil esa aceptación y esa
inclusión Qué mensaje tiene No solo para
los pueblos originarios sino para todo
el mundo básicamente
hemos caminado hemos trabajado por la
visibilidad por el respeto a nuestros
derechos porque al final somos personas
no somos
monstruos no somos nada raros somos
personas zonas igual que los hombres las
mujeres y todos los demás todas Tenemos
que trabajar todos los días para llevar
el sustento a casa y todos tenemos
derecho a vivir en un mundo libre de
violencia y discriminación en Juchitán
alzamos la voz porque hemos reconocido
nos reconocemos como seres humanos y
reconocemos que tenemos Derechos Humanos
ahora le quería hacer otra pregunta no
es ser
Perdón no pero es una una pregunta que
surge en todo este contexto no implica
necesariamente tener una tendencia
homosexual
bueno
pudiese ser por ahí por el mismo camino
no porque pues cada quien tiene su su
sexualidad como es no como te decía el
que es mucho es mucho el que ese hombre
es mujer ese hombre el que es mujer es
mujer
no no tenemos por qué jugar no podemos
ser hoy en día mucho y mañana no O nada
más jamás por moda o cosas así no
felina Santiago valdivieso Muchísimas
gracias llegamos al final de la
entrevista Le agradezco muchísimo su
presencia en francés 24 en español
Sí gracias por la invitación
disculpa por todas estas
situaciones del internet que no nos
dejan fallas técnicas cuestiones que
suceden Le agradezco una vez más a
nuestra audiencia como siempre le
invitamos a que sigan informandose en el
resto de nuestra programación y también
por supuesto en transmití 4.com 100
junto a nosotros
[Música]